[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
opening statements begin in the trial
for the death of ahmad arbury and as mr
arbory
runs toward him
he pulls up the shotgun and points it
out
the prosecutors describe arbory's last
moments of life while the defense fires
back made him willing
to put himself at risk
to help the police detain a mod arbor
and an unexpected outcome in a cold case
murder trial
realize the jury was unable to reach a
verdict on the other counts and that is
a perfectly acceptable way
for a trial to conclude plus the
defendant is guilty of first-degree
murder of a law enforcement officer a
verdict is issued and sentencing is set
for this weekend could convicted cop
killer markeith lloyd avoid the death
penalty again and later firsthand
account of the kenosha shooting it was
just surreal it was
i felt
scared about
what was going to happen
we had inside the courtroom of kyle
rittenhouse's murder trial law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i am imran ansari in for brian buckmeyer
who is in georgia covering the death of
ahmad arbory trial here in new york i am
joined by co-host terry austin
after weeks of jury selection opening
statements begin in the death of ahmad
aubry trial gregory and travis mcmichael
and william roddy bryan all face charges
of malice murder felony murder and
aggravated assault for the shooting of
24 the 25 year old jogger prosecutors
say that the father and son gregory and
travis mcmichael followed arbory in
their pickup truck as he ran near his
home in georgia back in february of
2020. travis mcmichael shot and killed
arboree and he's claiming self-defense
brian followed along in his own vehicle
recording on his phone
the trial is being held in a courthouse
in glen county georgia that's where our
very own brian buttmeyer is now joining
us
and brian we finally heard the highly
anticipated opening statements in this
trial tell us what you heard down there
in georgia
imran assumptions and driveway decisions
that's how the prosecution started their
90-minute opening statement and that's
what they laid out the assumptions that
the mcmichaels and william bryan made of
a mod arbory and the decisions they made
from their driveway
bob rubin the defense for travis and
michael said the case was about facts
and highlighted that there was tensions
in the community and that days prior
trousing michael confronted aubry and
believed that he was armed when he says
he saw aubrey reach for his left pocket
and that's why they chased him on the
23rd of february with guns frank hoag
defense attorney for greg mcmichael
highlighted many of the same points as
reuben but added that the assumptions of
who was in the construction site was
right william bryan's attorney kevin
goff preserved his right at an opening
statement to after the prosecution's
case and the trial moved on to its first
witness with an enhanced photo of the
shooting the prosecution highlighted the
moment before the deadly shooting of a
mod arbory as traffic michael stood
there with his remington 12-gauge pump
action shotgun
does travis mcmichael
raising up
his shotgun
the remington 12 gauge
how far mr arbory is
mr arby's under attack
he's being driven
forward
by mr brian in his pickup truck he's
running away from this pickup truck
that's already tried to hit him four
times
toward mcmichaels
travis mcmichael is out
of the car with his shotgun
and as mr arbory
runs toward him
he pulls up the shotgun and points out
trouser michael's defense attorney then
highlighted an increase in crime in the
neighborhood and that travis had a duty
and responsibility to help
this is the family
and community
that travis mcmichael felt a duty and
responsibility to
during the course of events in 2019 and
2020.
this is the
family and community that
made him willing
to put himself at risk
to help the police detain a mod arbory
crime had gone up
it wasn't violent crime
it was property crimes
the kind of crimes
that are unsettling
the kind of crimes that are scary
so brian we heard opening statements
from both mcmichael's attorneys but new
information we're hearing is that
william roddy brian's attorney is
reserving opening statements until after
the prosecution presents its case brian
what does that mean moving forward
[Music]
so what that means is that we're already
starting with the first witness william
duggan that's the officer who showed up
at the scene and we're seeing his body
cam video i'm being told that even one
of the jurors is shielding their eyes
because it's so graphic and even wanda
cooper jones can't watch it but after
the prosecution puts on all of their
evidence only william roddy brian's
attorney will have an opening statement
at that point then the defense will put
on their evidence and all parties will
have a closing statement after that
brian we are all watching to see how
this plays out thank you for your great
reporting down there in georgia
so this week on law and crimes cop tales
and cocktails podcast sergeant shawn
sticks-larkin an icu nurse howard dawe
sit down with former new york police
officer jason lakayo let's take a listen
he was a two-time he's a two-time fellow
so this would have been his third strike
and he would have went up north and
never seen the light of day
so he basically tells the kid that stops
him you know my partner at the time he's
like i'm listen bro i'm not going back
and they start fighting so
they get into a tussle and they fall
down a flight of stairs my uh my then
partner snapped his femur
for everybody
no that's the largest bone in your bone
in your body and when i'm telling you it
breaks you can hear it
like a chicken bone you hear it and when
i heard that and the scream that came
out of this dude's mouth like i start
bolting down the stairs and we're
chasing this dude
and i mean we chase this dude about
three or four blocks jumped on him and
when i'm telling you like the adrenaline
i like i could barely
breathe by the time we got to this dude
and he was still putting up a fight man
so you can listen to the latest episode
of cop tales and cocktails on apple
podcasts now or wherever podcasts can be
found and still ahead here on the law
and crime daily a sentence will be
handed out soon for convicted murderer
markeith lloyd but first a decades-old
cold case murder still without a
resolution what a mistrial means in the
case of colorado versus steve pankey
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad aubrey gunned down in broad
daylight we are going to make sure that
we find justice in this case the three
men charged will now stand trial i told
him stop stop stop till he hit me i had
nothing to do
there's nothing else i can do you're a
passer buyer coming through not
necessarily
that's my son that shot him i was in the
back of the truck
starting october 18th watch live capital
gavel coverage on the law and crime
network
[Music]
welcome back to law on crime daily and a
case nearly four decades in the making
ends with an unexpected twist in the
cold case murder of a 12 year old
colorado girl
ladies and gentlemen
the jury was unable to reach a verdict
on the other counts and that is a
perfectly acceptable way for a trial to
conclude
in a shocking outcome a colorado jury
declares a mistrial for seven-year-old
steve panky panky is accused of the
murder of 12-year-old janelle matthews
who went missing back in 1984. she was
last seen going into her greeley
colorado home after a school christmas
concert matthews was declared legally
dead in 1994 her remains were discovered
in july of 2019. that's when her cause
of death was determined to be a gunshot
wound to the head
panky who previously ran for governor of
idaho was a person of interest in the
case at the time of matthew's
disappearance his ex-wife told
investigators that in the days following
the disappearance of panky panky
panky showed unusual interest in the
case he also lived a few miles away from
matthew's home and was a pastor in her
church
panky was indicted by a grand jury more
than a year ago and his trial began in
october
while the murder and kidnapping charges
ended in a mistrial the jury did find
panky guilty of false reporting to
authorities this is based on direct
testimony given last month by pankey
himself
so the truth is
is that
i made a lot of stuff up
out of bitterness
for things that happened to me at
sunnyview
and for things
that happened to me at seven up
and
my revenge on them was to
[Music]
and because i hated the police it was
all in one to say
i've got information that you want and
you can't have it
it was a polite way of flipping them the
bird it was pure hatred on my part
okay let's break this down joining me is
my co-host terry austin and also guest
bernarda villalona also an alumni of the
brooklyn district attorney's office like
myself so terry i'm going to start with
you this isn't the verdict we were
expecting what could have caused the
mistrial in this case
you know i sort of did expect this type
of verdict it was not an easy case for
the prosecution the one verdict they did
come back with was the admission to
lying and that's because he admitted to
lying and so the jury said okay we're
going to find you guilty as far as
that's concerned but i think the rest of
it the kidnapping and the murder charges
were very difficult for the jury there
was no hard evidence in this case so
they had no dna they had no witnesses
and i think that the character of this
particular defendant played a large role
he ran for governor more than once he
was a pastor in the community and i
think it was hard for the jury to say
this type of person would have kidnapped
and killed a young girl and they didn't
see any hard evidence and they just
decided well look we're not going to
they followed the law they had more than
reasonable doubt and they could not come
to a guilty verdict on those charges so
it makes sense
yeah and bernarda what's the next step
here given that this case ended in a
mistrial
so since this case ended up in a
mistrial what the prosecutor is going to
have to do is they're going to have to
re-evaluate the case re-evaluate the
evidence does it make sense to go
forward and retry this case what would
be the likelihood of conviction when
you're dealing with a cold case because
the only thing that is going to change
between this trial and a new trial are
the jurors so the prosecution's going to
have to make that hard decision do they
retry him or do they just leave the case
as is and just have him sentenced on the
lying charge
we'll all be waiting to see and we will
see if there will be justice for janelle
matthews
to come but coming up here on law and
crime daily wisconsin versus kyle
rittenhouse witness testimony details
how victims were acting the night of the
deadly shootings in kenosha
plus the verdict is in markeith loyd is
guilty in his second murder conviction
but is a death penalty conviction in his
future our legal analysts break it down
coming up next
[Music]
welcome back a sentence will soon be
handed down to convicted cop killer
markeith loyd as long crime daily
reported this week lloyd was found
guilty on all five charges in his second
murder trial including the first degree
murder of orlando police lieutenant
debra clayton lloyd gunned down clayton
while she attempted to apprehend him for
the murder of his pregnant ex-girlfriend
chaude dixon lloyd was previously found
guilty for dixon's murder and sentenced
to life in prison he avoided the death
penalty in that case but now he faces
the death penalty again his second
murder trial lasted for eight days the
defense called 11 witnesses including
the defendant who took the stand for
nearly three and a half hours he
maintained that he was acting in
self-defense sentencing is to take place
this saturday
so let's break this down bernardo i'm
going to start with you this is lloyd's
second conviction he dodged the death
penalty in his first murder
first murder conviction what are the
odds that he avoids it again
so i don't think that this time around
he's actually going to dodge the death
penalty because with this jury this jury
is well aware that he was convicted of
killing sade dixon um as well as an
unborn child and also shooting her
brother so i think with that extra
information that
information that actually worked so
against him that the jury is going to
have a different perspective in regards
to the death penalty because unlike the
other case this case they know not only
did you kill a woman and almost killed
her brother but you also killed another
woman who so happens to be a police
officer
yeah and terry during the sentencing
phase we will hear victim impact
statements who do you think we might
hear from
well there's no question we will hear
from debra clayton's family members and
we know for a fact that her husband was
in that courtroom almost on a daily
basis and seth clayton will absolutely
have some words to say particularly
since we know that lloyd directed some
comments towards him so i absolutely
expect that he's going to say something
and he's going to mention the fact that
they had a son johnny who will now be
raised without his mother and that will
be a very serious impact upon the family
i also expect imran that we might hear
from some of the police officers who
were involved in the case or who just
know deborah clayton certainly the
individual who was shot at that lloyd
attempted to kill but i also think we're
going to hear from the sheriff in this
case he previously made comments saying
he could not wait until lloyd was
sentenced and and lloyd was convicted
and i think that he'll probably have
some comments to make during these
statements
right two convictions and we know that
florida is not shy about handing down
the death penalty so when we come back
the contentious case of wisconsin versus
kyle rittenhouse
we hear first-hand witness testimony
from three men all there the night of
the deadly shootings
[Music]
welcome back testimony heats up in
wisconsin as day 4 begins in the trial
of accused kenosha shooter kyle
rittenhouse 18 year old rittenhouse
faces multiple charges including first
degree murder reckless murder and
attempted murder following the august
2020 shooting in kenosha wisconsin
prosecutors say rittenhouse shot and
killed joseph rosenbaum and anthony
huber and injured a third man
rittenhouse's team argues that the
defendant was acting in self-defense at
the time of the shootings rinton house
was only 17 years old alongside
rittenhouse the night of the shooting
was reporter richard mcginnis he
testified what happened the night of the
shooting
it was just surreal it was
i felt
um
scared about
what was going to happen
what i would have to do
after that
because i knew you know
that i had what i had seen
i
i was i became more worried once i
realized that my phone uh wasn't
recording
why do you say that
um because
um
that made me realize that i
it was my eyes that saw it and that um
rather than just
being able to show
i'd have to tell
like you're doing today
yes
the jury also heard from military
veteran ryan balch who met rittenhouse
the night of the shootings bulge
testified that victim joseph rosenbaum
made threats to both of them before the
shootings
when i turned around
rosenbaum was right there in front of my
face
yelling and screaming
and
i would say dude back up just chill
i don't know what your problem is and he
goes you know what if i catch any of you
guys alone tonight i'm gonna kill you
and he said that to you correct
did he say that to the defendant as well
the defendant was there
so yes
and as far as you could tell the
defendant was close enough to hear what
mr rosenbaum said that is correct
jason lakowsky also met rittenhouse the
night of the shootings he confirmed with
defense attorneys what rosenbaum's
actions were leading up to the shooting
he is yelling shoot me and then
he uses the n-word yes
so he's saying shoot me n word shoot me
edward yes right yes
and
just up the backdrop here he's saying
this
at a protest
for an african-american man
who was shot by police correct
all right so let's bring in terry and
bernard bernard i'm going to start with
you the use of social media and live
streams have already proved to be a key
player in this case does all this
evidence help or hurt the prosecution's
case what do you think
so from the beginning of this case i
feel like the defense has been
benefiting more than the prosecution on
this case because every witness that
they called thus far the defense has
been able to profit off of them in terms
of creating some kind of seed of doubt
as to the charges because you're like
okay so yeah this happened i'm not sure
he was the initial aggressor no you know
i wasn't in fear no coward and house
didn't do this so while they have they
pushed the ball a little bit for the
prosecution to prove their case they are
also helping out the defense and it's
also clear to see that from the
witnesses that have testified that you
can tell that it feels like they're
stuck between a rock and a hard place on
whether they want to cooperate or
whether they want culver in-house to be
found guilty in this case i honestly
feel that the two charges that probably
are made out definitely so far is the
one having to do with the firearm being
that he possessed it and he was under
the age of 18 which is just a
misdemeanor that carries up to 90 days
in jail as well as the breaking of the
curfew order
yeah i agree and terry
several witnesses who went to the
protests with kyle rittenhouse were
trained in the use of weapons could that
hurt the defense or help it
i actually think that's going to hurt
the defense because you heard jason
lukowski say he was a u.s marine corps
and he was trained on the use of guns
and he knew how to handle himself he
encountered rosenbaum and he did not
shoot rosenbaum and i think the same is
true for ryan bulch he was an afghan
veteran and an iraqi veteran and he for
a fact also was trained and he didn't
respond so i think it's going to show
that kyle rittenhouse didn't know how to
use that weapon
right great analysis thank you bernarda
and terry thank you for joining us here
at law and crime daily we will see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you